attention attention attention c'est la
vie la commission l'impressionné pas
compris c'est dans ces prix-là 1 15 % +
c à c y et vous à ce niveau là c'est
comment anneau en or
excusez moi nous valons ces prix là nous
ne sommes pas des senteurs quelqu'un
nous avons du métier derrière nous
comment nouvelle mais 400 fauteuils à
l'olympia j'enjoins des pieds des 100
fauteuils au festival déconne et l'année
dernière
oui personnes et blessé donc trois
agents de la paix nous avons des
références
oui c'est ça on avoir attendu oui mais
hommage à madame elle est partie avec
toutes mes condoléances
on le voit c'est l'ami on s'est connus
non ça fait rien ça donne là que nous
allons agents super maman et qui dit je
vais voir si monsieur n'est pas en
conférence
je n'aimerais pas des prix attendue ne
quittez pas à l'eau alors comment va
tout we will secondes
j'ai très hâte à vous jouez de la
guitare bien très bien
oui mais vous allez vous la guitare
tourner et honnêteté la guitare taux ne
le quitta pas vous la guitare la rater
la tnt pavot ou la guitare il restera
très bien voilà il est très bien ces cas
sont à l'eau alors oui oh non ça va mal
tout ça va vraiment où s'esquissait
débordés nous vivons comme ici oui
depuis des mois dit gala par jour des
cocktails et premier à la publicité la
folie warhol craque
les nerfs lâchent dans son cou
ce serait complètement azimuté ses prix
ce responsable les couleurs alors agent
super maman ne quittez pas je vais voir
si monsieur badin conférence d'un parti
qui bien monsieur alou si le plus alors
non je dois on m'appelle les palavas les
flots
oui vous d'affaires très important
discours à moi hein je te rappelle tout
en leur mémoire à nous en permanence
monsieur bernard alaux ah c'est vous
monsieur le directeur
oui bonjour de quoi s'agit t ouais à vos
volets les grandes villes marc villemain
vraie place de nouilles et 44 ouais
c'est ça le bellemare oui c'est nous
louis sans témoin j'ai tout ce j'ai
jetterait oui dix mille francs pour la
commission la tour éléments auraient
tous frais compris celui de swala serré
qu'auprès des formes et risque de détail
de risque d'être risque d'ennuyer
matériel soins de première urgence
donc oui oui vous savez ce que c'est un
look un coup de poing partie la note
arrivent tous les sud-africains demandé
à johnny à transfère oui alors coûté une
seconde je vais regarder dans mon écurie
1 c'était et peut vous proposer pour
louisville frein nous avons johnny val
qui te lit enfin seulement à cognac
ouais c'est ça regardez vous connaissez
johnny vol n'en voudrait pas laisser ces
fériés pourtant il avoue une prix à
cognac
alors oui c'est trop cher à écouter
alors je vais voir poupe
nous pouv a pris pour samy sur une
formation terrible à vous proposer
c'est à non par essence et noir non les
socquettes blanches sera même chose pour
écoutez monsieur je crois que ce serait
plus simple de tout le monde ici comme
vous voulez mettre parce que moi je ne
sais pas mais c'est une question de
principe c'est tentant de regarder
regarder bas prix son intérim à
s'imaginer que nous souhaitons pour
notre plaisir vous une seconde
alors ouais de temps contre 7 alors
écoutez pour ce prix là c'est une petite
fracassant à vous proposer
oui quelle date légale quelle date le 18
vous êtes libre le 18 août et les
prévisions il est libre le 18 ouais
c'est ça pour comment il est écouté
vous connaissez les people 1 eh ben
c'est pas ça dure
tous les ans épouse ébouriffant encore
écouté il à la physique des johnny les
profils les profils d'un style vie oui 1
puis les yeux des gens portent un nom
par belmondo railleur la voie aux all
have one on sait pas où une voix c'est
tout nationale oui c'est une autoroute
au lycée lisse sans une chaos
voilà vous pouvez me croire vous savez
oui
son nom vous voulez savoir sont en votre
nom le bourdon bourdon à l'aube dynamite
ces bruits dynamite hic c'est qu'un
terrible voilà c'est entendu ça la vie
alors si vous avez les contrats à signer
en double exemplaire
oui signal c'est ça vous va envoyer avec
une petit chèque barré avons essayé
abandon bien sûr oui mais non ne me
remerciez pas c'est la vie c'est tout la
tourelle oui nous défendre et défendre
la chanson française au noir alors tes
petits seins
qu'est-ce qu'on ne vient pas propre à
l'europe mais on peut faire j'apporte la
guitare de monsieur bellemare
on a réparé on a réparé et de cornes
voilà la facture on vous a fait 10 % de
réduction
[Musique]